alright they go folks that's one down
five to go ea's conference okay let's
all have and put up our virtual
scoreboards for that out of time Scott
Butterworth well you wanna give
electronic dart not a lot of surprises
there and actually some stuff that I
really wish you'd seen more of like a
really wanted more in drama time what we
did see was pretty enticing but
everything great to get like actual
gameplay something like that yeah so you
know a lot of the kind of played it
saves a lot of really expected
announcements we go six okay generous
Lucy I'm gonna go seven all right they
had a couple of really nice things that
everyone seemed to ignore like the EA
originals all right they were talking
about giving money to charity all that
kind of stuff working with the old money
to charity working with special effect
and of course I completely loved the
Andromeda and the like the fee faith is
better than being so yeah we predicted
pretty much all of that but yeah we lost
we were right about yeah like yeah like
last year's unraveled it's the shears
fee although I like the idea of that
program that they're going to be
expanding that and watching I mean you
had you had your chance Jess scorecard
fair enough um yeah I think it's a hot
seven III enjoyed it I actually thought
I maybe I was more pessimistic I thought
we might see less of an aroma than what
we saw yeah i really liked everything
they said like everything they said
they're working towards for Andromeda is
basically like everything I've got on
the wish list like I can't even think of
anything that Lena I wish they'd teased
at related to that game that they didn't
and what we did see of even if it wasn't
you know an engine gameplay footage
looked gorgeous absolutely good fair
enough all right let's RAM through this
list of games everyone is watching on
the live stream they're starting to get
that battlefield gameplay event going
but they're gonna talk to Zac Efron and
Jamie Foxx for about 10 minutes probably
so it will be done and dusted by the
time nothing started to stick around
jazzed yeah for sure get your questions
in a twitch gamespot a shot as well okay
first things first titanfall 2 yes
already seen it that was probably like
of the footage they showed a look of the
actual gameplay that we saw during that
press conference that was probably
my favorite I mean it was also arguably
the deepest look at any of the games
that they were showing off in Star Wars
it gotta roll everything together but
titanfall it's like all right here's a
two separate trailers one for
multiplayer one for the single-player
campaign which we knew about but now hey
it's official we got this big trailer we
got the kind of creepy AI voiceover and
the sort of didn't get this relationship
between pilots in mex we had speculated
on but now it's really confirmed it was
nice seeing in action yes the one thing
that looks great i mean lets you can see
how like a couple of years as well as
really given this engine a bit of a bit
of breathing room but i like even like
that transitioning at the titans that
are already on the field instead of
pretending like they're just really
learning a lot like I mean obviously
race ones attain that's proved
themselves to be quite reliable but they
also seem to be massively listening to
what their fans want and stuff like that
yeah so the bear was like the big ask
from last year this gameplay looks great
it looks like the cooperating a lot of
sweet mechanic yeah from overwatch
change up the yeah there's tracers days
old they are going a lot of those right
sort of added mechanics that are layered
on top of the typical first person
shooter looking stuff sorry we're saying
I always say yeah yeah okay um yeah I
just I think it looks sweet I mean that
they look like they're you know
delivering on the grappling and
everything like that like they've
already got mobility down as such a
central theme of what titanfall is and
it just seems like they're just
expanding on that so it's like
everything is faster everything is
parkour and movement and skill based and
I don't know I think I think they got it
down I think they're on the right track
it's going to be testing with today with
the single-player campaign because
obviously in the multiplayer like
titanfall is based on his foundation of
you being able to move better and shoot
better than everyone else interested in
the single-player aspect of that at all
scott i'm happy to exist yeah i mean i
was definitely with the course of people
saying where's the single player I mean
that's definitely how I like to play
games and I think that there was you
know a lot of lore simmering under the
surface in the first guy that you just
kind of you you could tell was there but
wasn't you weren't really able to
explore it given there was a multiplayer
only game so I'm excited that they're
going to be able to really lean into
that stuff and give us more insight in
the universe and it seems like it's
going to lend itself well to a single
player experience so I'm excited to see
what they do with it yeah
real soon October 28 on pc ps4 and xbox
one okay they talk about eSports for
about 15 minutes should we just get over
that maybe eSports not everything yeah
it sure is they make it is i mean it is
the thing it is baseless is relevant is
relevance to the eSports crash it's
unlike the people who don't like it it's
like gaming right don't particularly
involve myself in it yeah personally but
I think it is very relevant and becoming
more relevant as as we move forward year
after year I feel like this is the third
or fourth year where there has eSports
has had a big crowds and III is just not
the place to spend that's probably sure
talking about I mean the famous III
isn't really the place where we hear
about pc games it's right yeah so anyway
let's move on yeah Mass Effect Andromeda
we got a dev diary well yeah I think
they're just gonna hold off for games
confiscates coming out next year so
they'll want to focus on battlefield and
want to focus on titanfall but I was
really to be honest I was expecting less
footage I was expecting saying just like
again the concept art stuff but what
what was interesting is that the concept
I that they were showing is the concept
art we saw it like two years ago but
this time fleshed out characters in it
better lighting effects more movement
and also first like a protagonist who
everyone was crying out for fem shep in
the original trilogy to be the face of
the trilogy and it looks like they're
leading with that at all yeah like that
one ship here The Tempest looks an awful
lot like Normandy yeah but what I can
like this cuz you also got to see a
relay is that they're kind of holding on
to the old mass effect in specially in
terms of hmm like just the look of it
and some of the Keystone's like like the
like the Citadel those kind of things
and some of the creatures and races but
they aren't afraid to be injecting new
things like this happy to hear these new
environments so we get Cena sorry she's
definitely in there and I think what
looks like a yog witch with a shadow
broker was so it's this real mashup of
old and new and I am super excited I'm
getting the impression like I think
planet exploration is going to be great
i mean because we know we know the Makos
on board we've known that for a while
which means I'm sure we're gonna be back
on the ground again and that's been less
of a focus more on the cities and things
like that presidium and all that so I
think that's going to be awesome and
just like how dedicated they seem to be
too how alien everything is going to be
ironically where the alien but I think
that's going to be great we're gonna see
less humans we're going to see them
branching out more I think like trying
out you know different themes of planets
different races and just you know they
know they can deep dive into law and
into like just completely invented
spaces and that we're going to lap it up
yeah so I think like because I've got
all that backing we should see some
super good [ __ ] exciting stuff I mean be
great if we saw some more of it at the
microsoft and sony's don't think so yeah
well wait and see FIFA 17 they showed a
bunch of that as well to a crab in
London who presumably doesn't really
care all that much about football
because the euros were literally on the
Germany Ukraine game was on I was
finishing as FIFA was was on so they
showed off sing a player stuff you can
never tell if he fuh you know we have a
clown that opening monologue for a
minute that that was unusual that way
it's the josee marini aveo no just
hunted yeah oh my god that's like this
mission sounds yours yeah duh yeah but
it was sort of a knowledge tonal shift
from the rest of them no one else was an
actor on the stage so yeah yeah they
show that off I mean the FIFA the
journey stuff we don't know how it ends
up will it be good like a fun night
champion stuff will be not so good like
the 2k16 and stuff I don't know we'll
have to what off the wing see least are
trying something new I mean it's yeah
feebas yeah that's interesting but the
first time they've added something this
large into the package in the bed two or
three years well off to wait and see
yeah they'd Arsene Wenger and Jurgen
Klopp on the screen and then Josie
Mourinho came out and chatted for a bit
they showed another trailer and then we
were into EA originals zoink for
Gothenburg not fair this is exactly what
they were talking about it did you call
the battery what EA does and I think
it's awesome and I'm glad that they want
to do it as a whole thing as well like
his and they'll be
they're recognizing they know they do
that and it's like well I mean Lily you
want to make a big deal out they want to
showed one yeah yeah don't want we think
effect oh he's adorable it looks like re
really blind part like re it looks a
little bit like tear away um from the
urchins yeah from the concept art I
thought it looked a little bit ly limbo
but obviously now seeing it in action
it's it's obviously purple and not like
am I I feel like I've played this game
about six times over the past two years
the TRACON yeah kind of I feel like
we're really getting to the bottom of
the well of these adorable little
critters yeah pinging former saying CI
a-- I'm yet to get sick of that all
right okay I'm just cynical when it
comes to those scary these dudes the big
towering guys around obviously the
things from Rico the foes yeah they're
kind of creeping me out so they go
that's fair yeah it was interesting they
named game we've seen today for sure and
then we had Star Wars a whole bunch Star
Wars and they had galaxy heroes and the
older public and Bala front I'm behind
him hey we just like me we're making
Star Wars games like you know we've
already made a bunch yeah some more
unnamed games that will probably come
out in the last couple years yes it it
didn't name any of these but did show
baby glimpses yeah little teasers of
three yeah one two three yeah so I guess
I win by default you do and new
battlefront 2017 coming from motive
coming out in 2017 sorry yeah about a
fun day showed a new action adventure
game calling out a visceral then they
had respawns third person game which I
said was in a different era yeah yeah
which acoustic kind of mean anything I
mean there's so good yeah big time line
to work with so yeah and the whole thing
kind of felt like one of those like
paper announcements where they use this
to like get a lot of talented people to
come and help with me games at the dev
that we you call that one actually Lucy
there was like an x-wing or a TIE
fighter in virtual reality no no that
was I was I you say what you said either
way we would definitely talked about it
and there was a little glimpse of it
just there they certainly look like
someone in a headset so that guy their
next wing this guy used to work on far
cry for right so it'd be interesting to
see if he went straight from that to
motive or respawn respawns looks
interesting because it's there they're
all about the lightsaber fights and I'm
instantly thinking oh man i'd love to
play somewhere Jedi Knight multiplayer
like I watching the lightsaber fights
right now is just really intense so he's
loving it yea big AMISOM take massive
fan of the sabers and then yeah they
went into the Capitol games a little bit
with what what they're up to open
sometimes oh I'm but yeah we saw a
little we sneak peek of three seconds
baby Hannah kami hey looks all right
julia is up for and it's pretty like the
market is like 11 yeah good boy Manny
standpoint um yeah yeah we get it for
that let's get some face time for both
Amy and Jade but yeah like yeah we're
heading huge Star Wars project in the
charge on both of those and they also
sort of said that there was a bunch more
content coming to the Old Republic
auntie Paula phones and stuff like that
so yeah I mean yeah he's making a lot of
Star Wars here case right yes yeah
hopefully we see some more gameplay of
some of them I just felt a little bit
like all you The Bling Ian oh yeah you
got the blue box you gave me enough to
like a plane but like not enough to say
she thinks so connect different segments
look at least a little bit of something
yeah come on x games smiles yeah yeah I
think it's crossed a visceral but no
well yeah we'll see yeah its battle from
still be multiplayer-focused if there's
gonna like the visceral game kind of
handle the single player status side of
things rice yeah I wonder they tip the
Hat like titanfall half as well guess
what off Twain see we have to wait to
see this little bit of this three
seconds yes hot gameplay action though
very important yeah yeah so everyone
just sit quietly it's like a bad way hey
all right so second man ok ok here we go
yeah high dynamic range I mean boom it's
real pretty there you go pretty very
suggestive banners waving in the wind
yeah little details soon yeah and then
that was it for Star Wars for a little
while and matching bra came out and they
showed it was kind of weird they showed
like a very short single-player likes
night from the trailer 15 second
yeah you want to sure why the false
start there that was a little odd like
we're gonna die easy with it and then
we're gonna show you the full thing in
three minutes time that's right yeah I
don't quite get the whatever it doesn't
matter well what's they finally showed
the full thing look pretty cool we're
gonna be piloting like Zeppelin's and
apparently an armored train or by like
the behemoth vehicles sounds very yeah
cool I wonder if they'll do anything
like that 2142 titan mode where you had
like a big you know ship do you have to
like take down I wonder yeah part of the
multiplayer perhaps this trade looks
alive you guys seen Lebanon that movie
the non-sticky Israeli tank movie where
it all takes place inside of a tank of a
lot of that happening there would like
all these dudes crowned in there so I
wonder if maybe that's part of the
single player yeah laughs it looks great
though doesn't it the single planes from
different peoples perspective right so
much or you'll get to play as the Harlem
Hellfighters home health is the British
do he gets plays chimney right yeah no
there's like Bedouin tribes they had in
like chasing after her train that's like
too much desert yes maybe not this
morning tactical yeah feels like a
heightened World War one I mean yeah cuz
we did at the start they were like we're
doing like a take on World War yeah yeah
it's just like obviously I think it's
just them being like we got a world in
one and I do think they've and they've
already said they've gone to a lot of
effort to research what was actually
used in combat and stuff like that and
incorporate heat so that into the game
but I think it just means at the end of
the day we're playing a battlefield game
and what needs to be about a full game
so I think people were quite worried did
that is that like we're so accustomed to
all the drones and the high tech that
like it would be seen as a step back and
let's be slow paced on whatever but from
this trailer released from the cut of
this trailer yeah definitely I think I
can expect high energy yeah yeah look at
this nonsense just high energy with
horses and tanks stabbing fool dabin
planes i play my playground put some
friggin windmills that's not a crossbow
lots of disability they also said there
was going to be like dynamic weather
coming into which they kind of i have
added into a bunch of the battlefield 4
and maps especially the ones in the sort
of ocean ones the island once
yeah it looks interesting and I was
basically that was CC a's press
conference they are apparently streaming
now the battlefields one multiplayer
thing so we will not hold you guys up
any longer and before I let you guys go
what was your favorite thing you saw in
ea's conference first of all mr.
butterworth titanfall 2 okay I reserve
the right to change that to Andromeda
when we see more right how do you see
what have you no matter okay I'm Jess
yeah Andromeda I just I yeah they're
gonna do it they're gonna do I have
faith yeah we didn't I am the optimist
speaking of faith no side of mirrors
edge at all like oh oh just came out
though you know good point at home
playing they go like hey and we just
released this one let's go buy anything
yeah probably played on the show floor
something just remind people yes yeah
but it'll be like I'm char the last of
us that year okay so that's the show her
for now that is one day five to go make
sure you hit that subscribe button hit
that follow on a YouTube hit the follow
button on twitch if you're on there if
you're watching on gamespot stick around
folks we will be back at six thirty
Bethesda's press conference starts at
seven we're already hearing rumors of
some crazy enhancements coming out of
there not in fact not stuff that leaked
last week so you may want to tune in to
that pretty late for the Europeans but
it'll be worth it I promise we will be
live right here on gamespot com force /
e 34 / live on twitch I'm on youtube
from 630 Pacific that is four hours from
there do the math thank you so much for
watching and we will see you then take
care
you